do you want to get the source code and
understand why this works or not if you
want to understand why this design is
better than that design
I mean you reverse engineering and
you're saying wait a minute why does it
have this extra little source of it why
is there this extra degree of freedom
here why is it this extra variable in
the system now maybe if there's no
reason at all but it may be oh it needs
that variable because in one state
that's representing too hot and then the
other state it's representing not too
hot and and and so it goes we use we use
the the comments on the source code to
characterize these surroundings are they
literal that's the comments because one
can only do this work when what they're
okay one can delegate what we're not
updating
have make any commitments to aboutness
of the states of motor ganglia and the
neural ganglia well I'll have to look
closely because I'm pretty sure I can
find where he did maybe he really though
Absalom and but that's that's what if
you think about it think about reverse
engineering a computer program and and
while you're doing this writing comments
which explain each little part now those
are those are heuristics for the benefit
of those who come later one understand
how the thing works and why and why the
parts are organized is there so it's a
it's a it's a very convenient way of
interpreting the machinery that you've
got when you're doing your reverse
engineering now I think that's what what
meaning is is the interpretation of the
machinery in that exactly that sense now
I think
as when we reverse engineer yes but see
why that's important yeah but but but
then you wanna know why does evolution
preserve it yes
why does evolution preserve it by us
because somebody's gotta do the
interpreting but what's the problem with
that just that comments on the reverse
engineering are heuristics that we use
in order to keep track of what is going
on in the actual distribution of
physical matter that constitutes the a
pleasure and it's neural circuitry as
opposed to attributions of properties to
that circuitry like charge or pH or mass
or protein composition right so and the
paper I turn around today on the
evolution of reasons goes into this at
the level of a please yet the policía
does lots of things for reasons but the
please it doesn't have know anything
about the reasons doesn't represent the
reasons doesn't know the reasons and
doesn't have reasons doesn't have
reasons but does things don't go on and
on there's reasons why you know trees
spread their limbs and why they send
their roots down the trees don't
understand that they don't need their
the beneficiaries but if you want to
know why asking for a reason there's
lots of reasons and you can these are
reasons a river
and we can do it there's reasons why we
sneeze and why we blink those aren't our
reasons we don't have reasons and those
reasons are reason are causes of a
certain kind well they are they are
their reasons their answers to the
question what for not answers to the
question how comin C sense about we
could just talk about the atoms in the
trees and cooker out what the please do
is out ever refer back to the dance part
about the chat about bringing water yeah
his answer to your laplacian demon
exactly i think but that's that's my
point what that is exactly the
difference which i think is the meaning
of meaning is in this efficiency helpful
so now counsel dyskinesia the appreciat
does things for reasons but it doesn't
appreciate reasons it doesn't represent
its reasons but it does things reasons
as we go up and get more complicated
eventually we get to organisms that have
more elaborate nervous systems that
don't just do things for reasons but
begin to represent their reasons here's
where I'm history here's why a mystery
emerges because what we know from the
work of KML and others is that our
hippocampus it's exactly the same
molecular and somatic gene process that
happens in the aplasia
the only difference is 10 to the 10th
neurons instead of 4 neurons and my
problem is our does age difference of
degree produce real reasons but really
that it reasons that the brain has well
we're not a pleasure
according to as Dan rightly said cousin
let me there's differences of degree in
differences of degree let's let's go way
up and look at a case I
disgusting for years and that's the the
injury feigning in the in the piping
plover now this is cognitively
controlled behavior it's quite subtle
and experiments that for instance Kevin
who named it moment did Carolyn written
estimate the Carolyn miss tab did we
know that that the look to her two
possibilities this is a sort of freaked
out behavior the bird is this sort of
having an epileptic seizure or it's
actually very close gravity and it turns
out it's pretty darn clever because the
piping plover is is monitoring the
predator even monitoring whether the
predator is gazing at her and if if the
predator is looking away she will stop
no she will amplify her walking as an
engine right she'll let the predator get
closer so there's this very subtle
process by which the piping plover leads
the predator away now are the reasons
why it's doing it yes
does the piping clever understand them
no but I can pilot over again is the
beneficiary of having a nervous system
the dustings for reasons that the piper
clubber does not have to appreciate so
we have to go up some more but the
brains are getting bigger and the
capacities for representation again and
just to cut to the chase I am NOT going
to say that animals are doing things
that they have reasons for what they do
so you get to us and a few of our
closest kin and here the reason I'm
going to talk about them actually
representing reasons let me go to the
easy case first and I've already said
this when you're consciously
representing reasons to yourself you I
mean you really are thinking about these
things you really whose actual processes
we're the reasons of themselves are
represented dogs can't represent reasons
to themselves chimpanzees can't
represent reasons to themselves finally
they can get close
Ruth Milliken suggests that when an
animal can represent goals and actions
in this sort of same space we're getting
close and I think that something right
about that but it doesn't solve the
problem because representation space
these are tricky words and you can pull
them a different [ __ ] but for the moment
I'm going to say we are the only ones
that represent our reasons and the only
reason we can represent our reason is
because in addition to having brains we
have language and it is has witnessed
symbolic species is because we have
language that we can represent our
reasons and so that we can be sort of
self conscious attentional systems and
be higher-order intentional systems in a
way that no other animal can be and then
we with this power that we have thanks
to life we can then look back at the
whole tree of life we can see all the
reasons the reasons why sponges do what
they do and why bacteria do what they do
and why why why oh please it does what
it does we are and it's heuristic we are
discovering the reasons why things
happen Darwin showed that all of these
reasons could be honored without any
representation of reasons by by an
intelligent designer we're the first
intelligent designers and we're the
first reverse engineers it's a
correlation between a neural state and
the external state right so whenever
it's a cat nearby some Pat part lights
up and some systemic
that just it's a picture Blas where you
call that causal covariant operations
but so is that and let me just flash of
an honest David if this is how it goes
through right I'm sure if I look in the
brain health I in a dog brain I'll find
correlations between neural firings in
Sona but you see yeah for the moment
uh-huh
I'm not going to call those
representations so what's the extra
magic that you have to put in there's
all sorts of correlations of the brain
I'm sure that's the case right why can't
I say that what what means that this
part of the brain is not representing
that part of the brain even the dog
since I'll certainly find the
correlations there it's a feedback of
the verbal tokens and the inscriptional
tokens onto conscious tokens well this
is the answer but it's not a common
answer okay but your ears you're saying
that if I had a richer sense of
represent I would see why dogs had it
and humans didn't have it and I
hopefully wouldn't no no no the other
way
oh okay sorry yes if I had a slightly
more sophisticated if I just didn't
reach my scientific theory
representation I would see where they
didn't go through this we were saying
you would see why what precisely why a
term like representation is so
problematic and you can see what we
might call the florid robust all in
concept of representation and those are
things like words and pictures and maps
and then we can see bye-bye
as it were courtesy once we clear about
what those are and see how people use
them how representation users use them
then we can look back on the brain and
see oh there's something which is rather
back in the in the animals brain and we
can see how in effect the animal brain
uses this in a in the way that people
use maps and if we don't find enough of
a similarity in the processes of
exploitation there there was a it's not
really a map it's sort of like a map but
don't think of it as a map because then
you're then you're imputed too much of a
map user too much of a map reader to the
system
you